my sleep habits were horrendous to say
the least
I mean I I've always had a hard time
sleeping we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is optimize our energy there
is one habit that I have adopted in the
last three years that has fundamentally
changed me as a business person wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the best
routines and habits that will shortcut
your path to success joy okay let's kick
it off with real number one sleep more
and meditate with Kobe Bryant lesson one
get an additional thirty minutes of
sleep a night take it as a challenge try
to find that space quiet your mind and
get your thirty minutes of sleep and
you'll see it makes a really really big
difference my sleep habits were
horrendous to say the least
I mean I I've always had a hard time
sleeping you know I couldn't figure out
how to shut my brain off so we made the
light bulb come on is that I went out
there and played the game and I played
like crap now it's like why am i playing
like crap because I've been practicing
these same moves over and over and over
but yet I couldn't execute them properly
I was feeling sluggish I was feeling
lethargic and I knew it wasn't because
of my training because I'd train
obsessively so then I started looking at
other things and that's when I came to
the realization that a cold you're not
21 years old anymore buddy maybe the
fact that she's sleeping two or three
hours a night maybe it has something to
do with the fact that you're playing
like crap and that's what I started
really evaluating those things and
that's a lesson to would be just five
minutes of quiet time five minutes for
you to be mindful and to just sit and
and find that inner voice and
and just kind of listen to the self and
preferably it would be in the morning as
you start your day I meditate every day
I meditate every day and I do it in the
mornings and I'll do it for about 10 to
15 minutes and I think it's important
because it just it it sets me up for the
rest of the day you know it helps me
it's like it's like it's like having an
anchor you know it's if I don't do it I
feel like I'm constantly chasing the day
as opposed to being able to be
controlled and dictate the day not that
you're you know calling the shots on
what comes forward but the fact that I
am set and ready for whatever may come
my way you know I have a calmness about
whatever comes my way and a poise and
that comes from starting the morning off
with meditation for me it's really just
just listening to my inner self that
there's that's basically it like you sit
in silence and you just allow these
thoughts to come forward and you get a
chance to observe the self and things
that may be lying beneath the surface
that if you don't have that time to sit
quietly on your own you'll never pay
attention to you know because if you
think about it
like the reality is we pay attention to
so many things that are going on around
us we're constantly taking selfies we're
constantly taking pictures to post on
Instagram and all these other things
we're constantly observing everything
that's around us but we don't take the
time to really observe what's going on
inside of ourselves and that's what
meditation is for me in 2000 we had a
new head coach that came to the Los
Angeles Lakers by name of Phil Jackson
Phil was just coming off and winning six
championships with the Bulls and he was
really big on mindfulness a really big
old meditation and it wasn't an option
for us so we sit in our film room and he
turned the lights out and he would you
would meditate as a group and he teaches
mindfulness and it really connected with
me because he was teaching mindfulness
through something that I was extremely
passionate about which was a game of
basketball
so it was told to the
of this is going to help you here and so
I had this curiosity about it and that
was my introduction to meditation and
then seeing the poise that we played
with the fact that we can be in a
hostile environment with fans yelling
and screaming and you know pressure
situations and it ended having no effect
on us because we were never too high
never too low we were just in the moment
and felt very secure and who we were and
that was my introduction of meditation I
had a great experience which really I
learned a lot about meditation to his
experience I was I was on a jet ski and
I took the jet ski out in the ocean and
I just kind of set and I just let the
current just take me wherever it was
gonna take me and I really saw a lot of
meditation through that moment because I
wasn't trying to control the moment I
wasn't trying to force myself upon the
waves and dictate where I was one of
God's let the waves taking yeah it was a
lot of peacefulness involved in there
rule number two get rid of your phone
with Mel Robbins
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person and it has also changed my
ability to manage my emotions so I don't
get hijacked I do not allow my phone in
the bedrooms I know the research
Deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33 percent of people are
reading emails in the middle of the
night I know that if you go to bed
and the phone is right next to you right
so you go to bed because you need your
phone you know if somebody might need
you and you sleep you know if this is
right here and it's not closed in the
blue light is on they've done studies
where you have people at a table and the
researcher will put their phone on the
table not even my phone
the researchers phone and the brain
lights up like crazy just with the
presence of a phone the research around
the phone and sleep is so stunning that
if you were to adopt one radical thing
today other than the five-second rule
try putting your phone outside your
bedroom
turn off the big little visit so you
don't hear it tell people who need to
reach you to call you my kids I have a
kid in college a kid who's just you know
high school kid in middle school if
there's an emergency call me there is
nothing happening on your phone at two
o'clock in the morning that's important
but if you allow yourself to become a
tool of this this is supposed to be your
tool for selling your tool for
communicating and we're all becoming the
tool here's the other thing common sense
why's that I want you to understand you
wake up the alarm goes off what do you
do so you're not even vertical and
you're reading emails and what is in
these emails other people's crap but you
don't have boundaries with this bucket
it's gonna impact sleep it's good
it's going to connect to my self-control
you have and so whenever I put this
thing outside the bedroom and I wake up
I walk over to where the phone is it's
plugged into my bathroom I turn it off I
don't look at it again I give myself
five minutes five minutes before I tune
in to the world to actually tune in up
here and say what's the one thing I'm
gonna get done today
that really matters to me if you're the
kind of person that feels like you don't
have control over your day make your day
gets hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball this one planning thing will change
your life no phone in the bedroom turn
it off when the alarm goes off five
minutes five lousy minutes five thousand
minutes before you tune in to the rest
of the world and if you've got the kind
of job where you've got to check it
get up ten minutes earlier you have
control over this stuff and it is so
important that you take it seriously now
because you're living at the slowest
moment of your entire life also if you
want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the links join on the
description below the fact that human
beings are strongest Drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves and I looked at it and I said
I'm not a brand I'm a person you might
want to get honest with yourself I can
study doing this via millionaire order
it is do you really because you can make
it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make honey
rule number three used a 20-20-20
formula with Robin Sharma one of the
lines from right out of the five am Club
is one of the DNA's of legendary is
longevity so if you look at the
Picasso's the jean-michel Basquiat you
look at the great sports champions you
look at the great history makers they
were much better at energy management
than time management and so we're in a
war against distraction right now and
what we really have to do is optimize
our energy how do I do it well I mean I
get to the morning routine which which
the whole book is based on but it's
really quite powerful because if you
start your day with sweaty exercise
you're actually going to activate a
pharmacy of mastery that exists
every human brain I know you love the
neuroscience you're gonna release BDNF
which is brain derived neurotrophic
factor that's going to actually
accelerate your processing it's actually
the repair brain cells that have been
damaged by stress you're gonna release
the neurotransmitter dopamine which is
the the fire neurotransmitter which we
all need as entrepreneurs and business
builders and and servants of humanity
cortisol the fear hormone is highest in
the morning so exercising first thing in
the morning is going to reduce that I'm
getting into my 20 20 20 formula but I
mention it because it is a way to
maximize your energy so talk to us about
the 20 20 20 I mean you sort of started
there with the the sweaty exercise but
what's the rest of that formula which is
pretty powerful sure so the new book is
all about rising at 5 a.m. and that's
because if you look at the great
creatives and the great Saints and the
great humanitarians and the great titans
of industry many of them got up at 5
a.m. even right now you've got Tim Cook
and you've got Howard Schultz and it
goes on and on before the Sun rises is
the time of least distraction before the
Sun rises where you can build intimacy
and fluency with what you want to stand
for in your day before the Sun rises and
the luxury and tranquility of the early
morning hours you can do that deep in or
work that will allow you to go out in
the world and play at your best so what
the 20-20-20 formula is is simply this
there's three pockets the first pocket
is move five to five twenty if you get
into the sweaty exercise because like I
mentioned it releases neurotransmitters
there reduces the cortisol increases
your metabolic rate which gives you more
energy so now and sort serotonin as well
which gives you joy so now it's 5:20
fundamentally you feel different you
have energy your state is strong you've
got a fire in your belly and you
accelerate your focus 520 to 540 is the
second pocket of the 20-20-20 formula
which is reflect we live in a world
where a lot of people are busy being
busy but what's the point of being busy
around climbing the wrong Mount Everest
and so clarity is one of the DNA's of
mastery you know this if you talk to the
titans of industry and you talk to the
people really getting traction around
their ambition these are people who have
a monomaniacal focus on the few things
that matter they have an obsession
bordering on a possession around the few
priorities they want to build our life
around
and so 520 to 540 the second pocket
you're right in the journal you meditate
you visualize you do what I call them
the book a blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect and
then the final pocket is 542 six o'clock
and this is the victory hour the final
pocket is grow but if you look at the
greatest billionaires I've coached many
billionaires over the last 20 years if
you look at the greatest producers on
the planet these people have one thing
in common they are ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
it no matter how much impact they have
they maintain a white belt mentality one
of the keys to epic performance is a
relentless commitment to daily growth so
that's the 2020 20 formulated that the 5
a.m. method is built around and the
premise is basically this as you begin
your day so you handcraft the rest of
your day and if you have consistently
great days you're gonna have
consistently great weeks quarters a year
and a lifetime so your days are life and
miniature and you've got to get those
morning's calibrated if you really want
to win rule number four prime yourself
with Tony Robbins
my very first thing I do when I wake up
in the morning is I want to get my head
right I do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate and I think meditation is
wonderful but I haven't met many people
that can not think thoughts this is a
different outcome this is about priming
yourself it's about putting yourself in
the state where your mind and body will
respond accordingly we'll do three steps
it's really simple over ten minutes so
why don't you sit down and I'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable I want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing gonna do is your hands are
gonna come up as you take the breath in
and then you're gonna explode out the
nose down explosive that's it good
that's it keep going two more good now
relax keep your eyes closed
hope your hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that just feel
whatever you feel just take it in you
don't have to respond to me anymore you
just enjoy it take it in and now just
let your body relax deeply and I'd like
you to begin to think of a moment in
your life you could feel really grateful
for if you wanted to it could be
something little rich or it could be
something big it doesn't matter it could
be from your childhood or this week it
doesn't matter
do your best to remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping in your body and seeing
what you saw then through your own eyes
hearing what you heard then feeling what
you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it feel it fill up with it and now
we're gonna ship to the last piece
really simple all you're gonna do is
focus on three things one at a time that
you want to accomplish three things you
want to achieve live it and feel it and
experience it
I was not
yeah put your feel there's two worlds
the master the external and the internal
world they both have to be bastard but
if you act master the external world you
know Allah you know Robin Williams you
don't master the internal world there's
a big price this is the one the master
first and so I start my day by making
that so I have this base to do it I'm
gonna live from gratitude today I'm
gonna live from blessing you know I'm
gonna be a blessing people's life today
I'm gonna get stronger today and I'm
gonna achieve what I'm here committed to
do and the whole thing you know we did
that one of the less than 10 minutes to
give you an idea I mule number 5 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have a good evening routine with
dhandapani how do I start my day on the
positive side I often wake up anxious
and stressed well Craig thank you very
much for sending in your question I
would like to respond by first asking
you a question and my question is what
do you do before you go to sleep at
night see most people before they go to
sleep at night either checking the email
on social media watching violent TV show
horror movie or reading a scary book all
of those things can make you have a very
restless sleep and chances are when you
wake up in the morning you could feel
very anxious and stressed so for example
if you go to sleep thinking about what
the new subconsciousness is going to be
involved throughout the night on the
work-related issues and when you wake up
in the morning channels now you can be
anxious and quite stressed about it as
well so the best way to wake up not
feeling anxious of stress is to prepare
to go to bed and that's not something
that people do very often here are a few
simple things that you can do to prepare
to go to bed you should stop working at
least half an hour before you go to
sleep so turn off your email don't go on
social media just completely shut off go
take a shower
prepare to go to bed and when you get to
bed sit on the edge of you keep your
spine straight your head nicely balanced
on top of your neck take a slow deep
breath in and then
exhale again and while you're doing this
deep breathing exercise focus entirely
on your spine and if you can't feel your
spine gently move your back from left to
right a little bit so you can feel your
spine focus on your spine as you breathe
in deeply in as you exhale slowly as
well and then just lay down on your back
and go to sleep and obviously this is
going to take practice you know work the
first day the second day but if you
consistently do this every night before
you go to sleep you'll start having
really good deep restful sleep and I
wake up not feeling anxious stressed now
I've got a special bonus clip with
jockle willing on how to have a strict
sleep schedule that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what will be your evening routine
tonight number two how will you prime
yourself tomorrow morning and number
three how can you use the 20-20-20
formula and if you made it this far in a
video and you are committed to making
the change I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believe down the comments
as well from my perspective when people
ask me all the time though I lack
discipline how can I get discipline of
my life and no one wants to hear this
answer no one wants to hear it just do
it the one of the first steps you can
take to impose discipline in your life
is to wake up early in the morning cuz
let's face it when the alarm goes off
you're you got your head on that soft
pillow it's all nice and cozy and warm
in there you do not feel like getting up
and so you hasn't even have a snooze
alarm he doesn't ever hit the snooze in
- and you should not you should not that
snooze alarm is that's insane I call
that snooze alarm the dream killer like
when you put on you when you press that
snooze button you're killing your dreams
so don't don't touch this button now
what I get now some would say that might
be a little extreme know where people
get worried and people freak out yeah is
sleep is healthy sleep is good for you I
know that I get it and people say you're
telling people not to sleep no I'm not
telling people not to say you do six
hours every night yeah I usually go to
bed around 10:30 11:00 and I wake up at
4:30 so I
five and a half to six hours almost
every night you know and and and
sometimes I tell people I
I think sleeping is good I do it almost
every single day no but but people will
freak out and say you're telling people
to be unhealthy I'm not saying that at
all I'm not you know if you need
different people are they have different
genetic needs for sleep I'm one of those
people that doesn't need much of my four
kids
my oldest daughter needs even less sleep
than I do my middle daughter sleeps more
like my wife my son somewhere in the
middle which by the way that means my
middle daughter she gets out of bed when
you get her out of bed
she likes to sleep so I'm not telling
people hey don't sleep but I am saying
put yourself on a schedule and you know
you ask why I don't sleep in if you
sleep in if I sleep on a in on a
Saturday until six o'clock ooh that
night I'm gonna have more energy and
instead of going to bed at 10:30 or
11:00 I'm gonna stay up until midnight
because I got a little bit extra sleep
well now that next day I'm gonna sleep
in a little bit more than all of a
sudden Sunday I'm sleeping in till seven
o'clock now Sunday night I can't go to
bed until one o'clock in morning him you
see where I'm going with this I go into
Monday with a lack of sleep because I
couldn't fall asleep so I just the most
important thing is set a good wakeup
time that works for you or you get
enough sleep and then wake up that time
every day if you can
if you want to know how to attract
success this year check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I want to explain
something to you that not many people
really understand I want to talk about
the law of attraction